this is why i mean it's funny because i
think that you know the issue that you
started to become really politically
prominent on which is the the bill c-16
in ontario and and
canada
the gender issue yeah now that's the
issue where
now the question that's constantly being
so why do you even care why do you even
pay attention and the answer is because
i was asked that earlier today oh really
what did you say
i'm not letting the cat have my tongue
yeah it's like it has nothing to do with
gender as far as i'm concerned or that's
peripheral in some sense so the
accusation why do you care fair enough
it's like
you know in some way people can go to
hell in a handbasket if it if they're
inclined to now i would rather have that
not happen but
people
are
what would you say
doomed to their own autonomy
but i'm not saying words that other
people want me to say and the idea of
compelled speech it's like the bill was
this much about gender right and it was
this much about oh yeah the government's
going to tell me what to say hey but now
they're regulating what therapists can
say therapy sessions this is interesting
because to me the the problem with with
a lot of this is less a free speech
issue even though i'm
on the same page with you uh and to me
it really is a fundamental truth issue
meaning that yeah you're trying to force
me to say something i don't want to say
but to me the the fact that what you're
trying to force me to say is so innately
opposed to the good
is
is the problem like you could you could
try i would have objections to you
forcing me to say that i like a
particular movie right it may not be
true i don't like the particular movie
it would be bad if you tried to force me
to say that but the the level of passion
that i have for issues like this one
really go to the fact that i think the
fundamental good of humanity relies on
basic acknowledgments of biological
truth especially when it comes to gender
and and anybody who's ever dealt with
children i find myself getting
you know i i if i look at my own
political evolution i'd say that when i
when i grew up i grew up in a religious
home so that means that pretty
conservative and then you go to college
and you're living by yourself and you're
not married you have kids you tend to
become a little bit more libertarian
which is like okay you know let
everybody do whatever they're going to
do and it's not going to bother me and
then you have kids and you realize that
there's a pool in which we are all
swimming and that pool is going to
define virginia virginia exactly exactly
like my kid it's going to determine how
my kid lives and i want my community to
reflect some of my values because i
don't want my kid to live in the toxic
sludge that you are that you are
creating for my kid i don't know well
there's doctrinating my kids in
that's what virginia demonstrated like
you can come after me but you come after
my kids and that's a whole different
story it's so fundamentally opposed to
everything true and the fact that
and that's the insistence the insistence
isn't that people be treated humanely or
be treated decently the insistence is
that your vision of yourself be
reflected by me in defiance of baseline
reality and
in order to redefine
how society as a whole well a lot of
it's murky thinking you know if someone
asked me do i believe that there are
gender fluid people
i would say
yes
and i would say
a man who's a young man who's gender
fluid i i know what he's like
temperamental
he's high in agreeableness
he's high in neuroticism so he has a
feminine temperament he's more
interested in people than things
and he's extremely high in openness
and so his temperament is fluid he's
creative and so he's one thing one day
and one thing the next and his
fundamental temperament is tilted
towards the feminine but that doesn't
mean he's not a man exactly so that's
and then so it's murky thinking so
that's exactly right it's certainly the
case that one out of ten women now it
depends on where you put the cut off
but you could say with
reasonable certainty that one in ten
women has a masculine temperament and
one in ten men has a feminine
temperament
and so that's a lot of people and those
people especially if they're also
creative
well they're they're kind of at a loss
in relationship to what to do with their
identity because they're pulled
first of all they have a hard time
catalyzing their identity creative
people have a hard time catalyzing it
it's like the definition of creativity
they're protein
and so they're there have been people
who play at the edges of gender identity
forever and fair enough and sometimes
that's even admirable if it's done in a
sophisticated way and it's charismatic
so you see it in mick jagger you see it
in david bowie
you see it and you see it in people like
madonna as well because madonna had a
hard edge you know that was very
masculine and all the marvel superhero
women have a hard masculine edge and so
we find that charismatic because those
people are also integrated but the
notion that
there's such a thing as gender
that's not right there's variability in
personality and temperament and the idea
that right that there's no such thing as
biological sex that's that's that's just
insane it's insanity they've they've
abstracted gender from sex and then red
gender back into yeah it's more
important than sex it's coming well and
then why insist upon the biological
modifications right if there's no such
thing as sex it's like what then just
act out your role right leave your body
alone because it's irrelevant anyways
well it turns out it's not irrelevant
you have to go through the surgical
transformation which is a pretty
dramatic answer to a question that for
99 of people who are ambivalent about
their gender identity would be best
solved without surgical intervention and
then this so now
in canada because they ban conversion
therapy it's now all affirmative
affirmation therapy right this is
there's no such thing as affirmation
therapy right now
it's insane i mean the the
the the semantic game that was used in
order to say well conversion therapy
which was at one time electric you know
using electric shock to treat
homosexuals
and saying that that's the same thing as
you have a gender confused 12 year old
look i had a 14 year old kid who was a
client of mine
and uh
you know he was in the
mid stages of puberty he was a pretty
creative kid
agreeable kid as well right not support
so he had a bit of a feminine
temperament that also meant he could be
pushed around fairly easily
well there was an aggressively guy games
gay guy in his schools hitting on him
and trying to convince him that he was
gay
well he didn't know
so he wanted to talk to me about it it's
like well i was going to tell him i
didn't what the hell do i know about
this kid exactly you know and i wanted
to hear what his problems were and how
it might be sorted out what he wanted
and like that's that's what you do in
therapy is you help people sort out
their problems now this idea is you come
to me with an axiomatic claim
whatever it is about your identity and
my job is to rubber stamp it it's like
that's not i'm not a therapist then so
this is not only insane
this insistence
like i like to think of truth untruth
and anti-truth
right and the notion that therapists
affirm is an anti-truth because
look let's say you come to me and you
say uh you have a proposition about
yourself and i say no i'm your therapist
no that's wrong it's like
that's not good therapy
but neither is you have a proposition
about yourself and you're disturbed
enough to come to a therapeutic session
and i say yes you're right it's like i
don't know if you're right
and if you're so right why are you here
like what are we talking about you're
already right it's a destruction of
basically the only form of therapy that
we know to work yes cognitive behavioral
therapies yeah it's all about
so are the rest of them they're all
predict this is one of the things that's
interesting about clinical psychology
every single school of psychotherapy is
predicated on the idea that free
expression of thought or or the free
transmutation of behavior is curative
and true with cognitive behavioral
therapy just like just like
psychoanalytic therapy it's all the same
thing and also the other axiom of
therapy is
voluntarily expose yourself and measure
doses to what you're afraid of
and so that's an interesting thing
because the psychoanalysts believed when
the behaviors first came up with
exposure therapy they had it formulated
wrong
they thought you learned to be afraid so
you're you're normal
and then something hurts you and then
you learn to be afraid that's wrong
you're always afraid except when you
learn not to so they had it exactly
backwards neuropharmacologically and it
really matters this this is this
this matters that doesn't mean you can't
learn some fears you can but mostly you
unlearn terror
right so children are afraid to get away
from their mother it's because they're
afraid of the entire world well you have
to learn how not to be and you don't
learn that by habituation because that
was the idea so you take someone who's
afraid they've been conditioned to be
afraid you expose them to what they're
afraid of and then you have them do
relaxation exercises so they counter
condition
well then it was discovered
and they don't have to do the relaxation
exercises
it's like oh well it still works just
exposure it's like well
they get less afraid
when you expose because their fear
habituates like so then the
psychoanalyst said well if they get less
afraid of that particular thing the
symptoms are just going to substitute
because that fear of an elevator say was
reflective of the deeper fear fear of
death had a client i exposed to and
elevated the doors open she said that's
a tube
and her fantasy about the elevator was
it was a place she was going to die in
of a heart attack while people were
discomforted and
what would you say made
contemptuous of her foolishness while
she was suffering and dying so social
alienation and death that was the
elevator for her so we expose her to the
elevator what does she learn
not to be afraid of the elevator no no
no
she learns she can tolerate those fears
she learns to be brave
and so the psychoanalysts were exactly
they were diametrically wrong because if
you expose someone to anything they're
afraid of
effectively they get
less afraid of everything
right and so that's partly why
psychotherapy is curative in that matter
is that people discover that they're
bigger than their fears they don't
discover that the fears are trivial i
think that the cult of authenticity is
going to be the destruction of all
psychotherapy and then because if the
cult of authenticity is that your true
authentic feelings are what makes you
you then the attempt to
make you brave in spite of your fears is
a suppression of your fears it's almost
like it's almost like a freudian
analysis of you're suppressing your
sexual desire and this is not full
authenticity yeah right why isn't the
fear of you right exactly authentic you
exactly and i think that that's that's
kind of where we're going it seems like
yeah well so this this this this
movement towards unity that we were
talking about this is a place i think
where
like informed liberals and conservatives
could meet
it's like well there is this
authenticity let's say in drive for
adventure and you see that
elevated to the highest place in some
sense in the more careless disney movies
but
the full manifestation of that in an
integrated sense
is the drive towards authenticity inside
this higher order unity it has to be
because otherwise it's disuniting it
causes fragmentation and chaos and so it
has to be subordinate to a higher order
end and then you might say well what is
that part of that's the reciprocal
reciprocal altruism that the
evolutionary biologists are always on
about it's like
some for you some for me some for you
some for me in measure right and that
makes both of us richer
and so that's part of the higher order
unity and people are intensely
reciprocally
altruistic that's great it's good if i
can get a re-up something awesome
okay okay and so um
it's authenticity in the service of what
now when pinocchio becomes real
he's already rescued his father right so
he's established an accord with the
tradition that gave birth to him already
he's revitalized that so when he wakes
up he's not free
he doesn't have any strings on him
anymore but he's already existing in a
harmonious relationship with with his
father it's a big deal and one of the
lovely things about what happens to me
as a consequence of my lectures is that
lots of fathers and sons come up to me
and say
we've really worked out our relationship
it's like they're both like you've never
seen
smiles like that
it's really something to be stopped on
the street and to be told that to see
people so joyful about that because it's
their heart desire you know
and that's that integration of that
drive to autonomy with well with the
family with the father with the mother
the broader community all that has to be
in a higher union exactly that's the
conservative insistence right exactly is
that there are these
the wall as you said before the walls
have to exist you can have autonomy but
the autonomy has to exist within the
walls and then once you let the autonomy
or the rationalism destroy all the walls
there's no autonomy without the walls
right just chaos
you